after texas democrats packed onto
private jets
proudly posing without masks flying to
washington dc to avoid voting
on texas election integrity bill last
week
two of the first three texas lawmakers
who tested positive for covid
met with vice president kamala harris
look you can see it in the photo
and there are always receipts these days
right the crew also met with
other democrats who applauded their move
including new york senator kirsten
gillibrand
and senate majority leader chuck schumer
and appeared all around capitol hill
mostly
not wearing masks again we don't know
the vaccination details on these people
but we do know that now more than double
the number have
tested positive for covet now just
imagine
just for a second imagination experiment
here
the media reaction and what it would be
if the people in the scenario
were republicans pete hexa
oh harris that is the right place to
start there are some moments
when that is exactly the way you need to
think about it to understand not just
the hypocrisy this is not hypocrisy this
is the home team
this is the media which has been covet
obsessed
covet obsessed for a year and a half
before they were of course trump access
obsessed completely they now are happy
to completely ignore
this example of a blatant what do you
want to call it a super spreader event
whatever you want to call it
because it is their team and so they
ignore it
uh and as a result we have to learn
about the trickle out and we're the only
people talking about the fact that
they came all the way across the country
in a private jet without masked
and ultimately they're confirming the
point many of us are trying to make
which is that if you have the vaccine
life should go back to normal yet this
they're trying to treat it that way
publicly but privately they're
reasserting mass mandates
and telling us that the delta variant
may actually
mean we're having to roll backwards so
there's a lot of sides to this story but
the republican comparison
is spot on harris pete actually
the first day kaylee remember on the
couch when we were together in studio i
said to you
well if they're all vaccinated this
would be a tremendous
poster for the white house to use
because they're not wearing masks
now suddenly crickets because we aren't
getting the question asked we don't know
how many of those people were vaccinated
we have no idea what the configuration
was but covet is spreading it's not
quite a super spreader yet but the
numbers are growing they've doubled
more than doubled in the last day or so
yes that's right and look
we wondered the new york post editorial
board did rather
you know what would happen if these were
republicans on the plane that had spread
coronavirus you know five people
testing positive well guess what we
don't have to wonder because we have a
pretty clear parallel example here it
was when i was in the white house
president trump tested positive hope
hicks myself many others vaccines were
not available at the time
do you know what the headlines were
harris vanity fair
said covet infested trump ramps up the
chaos in the white house cesspool it was
a cesspool
cnn just lamenting the fact that he
returned to the white house
they went nuts i had reporters calling
my phone
with information that had leaked about
young staffers of mine kids just out of
college i have reason to believe
so and so tested positive their personal
health information of course there were
the seating charts from the amy coney
barrett
confirmation event it was breathless
negative
coverage but here they go away unscathed
because they have that
beautiful little d on the end of their
name and that stands for democrat
let's give leslie marshall a chance to
rebut some of the comments here if she
chooses leslie i have a d
at the end of my name and it was
irresponsible i don't care if you have a
d
you have an r whatever your initial is
and this is why
uh harris this is why you know people
have the belief and i see it out there
on social media i even i even hear it
people that call into my radio show
there's a belief that if you're
vaccinated you are
immune from getting coveted that is not
true what you are immune from the
experts the scientists the doctors say
is death being on a ventilator or being
in the icu because that's what we're
seeing with the unvaccinated right now
this was irresponsible even if you are
vaccinated you're supposed to still be
wearing a mask especially in a small
space as they were
on that plane and you know if anything
this just shows
look you need to be vaccinated because
i'm not hearing about any of them on a
ventilator or in the icu
and we're seeing alarming numbers in
some of our states whether it's children
or people
uh 30 to 55 years of age now because we
know
that this delta variant is a stickier in
our lungs that's what doctors and
scientists are saying
so this this clearly was irresponsible
it was
it was wrong to do and i don't care if
they're just taking their masks off for
a moment do we know that for a photo op
but still they're in a small space
they're traveling they know better
leaders democrats
need to lead by example if this was for
a photo op
if this was for a photo op then i should
never have seen pictures of a woman's
underwear among those runaway democrats
it should never have gotten to the point
where they were bragging about
being runaway uh texas democrats not
calling themselves that but
boasting about this political ploy
because if we step away from covet for a
minute we cannot unfortunately run away
from what we saw inside that woman's
hotel room because she wants to say
she's sacrificing
emily that's exactly right harris and
just to build on pete's
points that were so true you know covet
has been the sun around which the media
and this administration has orbited for
the last year
it is the reason our individual
liberties were suspended
it's the reason why the borders were
opened it's the reason why
the the federal government still
maintains mass mandates throughout
airports
and every single federal building it's
the reason behind literally every
decision
according to them for spending
withholding
and um and more spending of uh of money
and suspending of rights
and so the fact that this stunt now in
such a dramatic
self-manufactured way likening
themselves to selma
and suffrage and other points of history
in which people
died protecting what were their
constitutional liberties the actual
inner
freedoms the fact that they liken
themselves to that
rashly exist in this plane and then have
zero consequences for this
no wonder the only institution in which
the americans have
less faith in this country other than
the media is congress
wow pete i want to go back to you um
who has the power now among those texas
democrats to say
it's not working out we need to take
that plane that the republican speaker
of house has
standing by get on it and go back and
get
everybody on the record with whatever
their votes are talk on the floor if you
need to
who's got the power to do that would
that be like a chuck schumer i mean is
there anybody among the democrat they
met with the vice president that
she loved on them for it that's a really
good point harris i actually do think
it's
national democrat leadership who've been
using them as a stunt as
puppets as props from the beginning to
push
hr1 so if any member of the democrat
leadership said
your stunts done because it's always
been a stunt because you're all you're
going to lose you don't have the votes
they can
call a special session so this does this
is
this is at the footstep of the white
house today that's where the leadership
is supposed to be stunt's over
failed miserably go back home and vote
go back home to texas where you say the
civil war is happening
go back to the front lines do your job
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now